Welcome back, everyone
It's Charlie.
This is going to be my Council of Kangs
video for Avengers 5 Kang
Dynasty, Secret Wars, Loki, Season
2 and Ant-Man and The Wasp Quantumania.
There's so much stuff to talk about.
So many teasers and Easter eggs
for what's happening next.
The next place, the Council of Kangs,
the Kang variants will appear
is in Loki Season two.
Of course
I'll be doing episode video for that.
Just like Loki Season one.
Be sure to subscribe to get those Marvel's
secret Invasion series with Nick
Fury will come before that.
That's also connected
to the overarching Marvel Phase 5 plot,
but it's less connected
specifically to the Council of Kangs
and what's happening on Loki.
Season two in Avengers Kang Dynasty
all do separate secret Invasion videos.
When we get more footage for that.
Careful for spoilers
for Ant-Man and the Wasp Quantumania.
If you haven't seen it yet.
But at the end of the movie, Ant-Man
and the Wasp seemingly quote unquote
seemingly Get Kang
the Conqueror sucked into his multiverse
engine core and then it blows up,
leaving you with no body but wondering
what actually happened to him.
At the very end of the credits, there's
an ambiguous message
that reads Kang will return.
So Marvel wants you to wonder
if Kang the Conqueror really died.
The line Kang Will Return
is meant to reference both him
and all of his variants
on the Council of Kangs.
Like every Kang will return,
they're going to appear in a bunch
of different Marvel movies and Disney
Plus series heading up to Kang Dynasty.
But for the most part,
the culmination of that
will be in Kang Dynasty because he remains
calls them the dynasty of kangs.
In the first Post-Credits scene, Immortals
Scarlet Centurion and Rama
Tut discuss the aftermath of Kang
the Conqueror disappearance.
Quote unquote.
They begin plotting to kill the Avengers,
other superheroes from other universes
who have been able
to touch the multiverse because they think
they threaten their dynasty.
Their dynasty of kangs.
There is referring to characters
who either know how to cross
into other universes like Doctor Strange
or have started messing
with the multiverse in a bigger way.
Like Scarlet Witch,
also Scarlet Witch character
that people thought might have died.
But she's definitely not dead.
She's definitely coming back.
It's a marvel movie.
It's a comic book movie.
If you don't see the body,
it means they're probably not dead.
But basically they're telling you
in this first post-credits scene
that it's going to be the new Avengers
team versus the Council of Kangs
in Avengers Kang Dynasty.
There are thousands of Kangs
on the council.
It's meant to be every single variant
like a Morta says.
I called all of us, every single Kang
that's alive in the multiverse.
The other really thing that got me excited
in that first post-credits scene with
the Council of Kangs was the Doctor Doom
variant of Kang, and that
just a version of Kang that's pretending
to be Doctor Doom in present day.
Everybody waiting to see what Dr.
Doom is going to look like the first time
we see him in the MCU.
It just
sounds like one of the upcoming Marvel
Disney Plus series or movies will see him,
but it'll really be Kang
just pretending to be him.
The council does exist in the comics.
The whole first Post-Credits
scene is designed
to look exactly like the comic book panel.
They even end on the face of that super
messed up Kang.
Just like in the comic,
it's meant to be
kind of like the Council of reads,
just a bunch of them from the multiverse
who band together to pool their resources
and power to control the multiverse.
It shows that the Council of Kangs is a
little bit more like the Council of Rix.
In fact, the Council of Rex was originally
based on the Council of Reeds.
So you see people making a bunch of Rick
and Morty references
to the Council of Kangs.
It's actually fairly accurate ages
that the Council of Kangs in the comics
came a long time before
Rick and Morty ever became a thing.
Would they show the council
in the Post-Credits
scene is pretty accurate to the comics?
There's always a handful
of the most powerful versions of Kang
who rule the council in the MCU.
There was an Easter egg
for this during Loki season one,
when Loki and Sylvie enter,
he who remains Citadel at the end of time.
There are four statues of the timekeepers.
One of them is broken.
When this episode aired, Marvel said,
Wait, wait, we'll explain this later.
We can't talk about it
now, but it's a big thing.
Cut to now, based on what Kang told
Janet Van Dyne about his back story
with the Council of Kangs,
the broken statue
is meant to represent him
and it was broken after he was exiled.
The four statues are meant to represent
these three kangs and the exiled one,
the Kang the Conqueror variant
that we saw in Ant-Man and the Wasp,
the funny thing about this too,
is if you think about it,
this is the first timeline
that we were talking about
because he who remains dies
and everything plays out again.
The Council of Kangs comes back, Kang
the Conqueror gets exiled to the quantum
realm again.
The funny thing about this
is that you actually wonder
about the actual timeline, how this works,
because he who remains would have had
to create that after he killed
the rest of the Council of Kangs.
Kang the Conqueror
actually references this.
It sounds more complicated
than it actually is.
So in the original timeline,
you have a bunch of different universes.
You have kangs rise up and all them.
This Kang the Conqueror travels
to the end of time and sees
the end of all reality,
like the collapse of all reality.
Basically the events of Avengers
Kang Dynasty and Secret Wars.
He develops a very Thanos
like plan for balancing the multiverse,
like saving the multiverse by destroying
a bunch of dangerous timelines.
So he gets exiled from the council
because they think he's too dangerous.
Just like Thanos got exiled from Titan
for wanting to kill
half of the population
randomly to save the planet.
Normally
you think the Council of Kangs wouldn't
care about erasing timelines
because they messed with time
so much as Kang the Conqueror says,
They're the ones we broke time.
All the bearings of me broke time.
But Jonathan Majors
also just confirmed something really huge.
He confirmed in the MCU.
Kang is meant to be another nexus
being like Scarlet Witch
in the Marvel movie, people have changed
what this means in the movies.
In the movies, it's meant to mean
that you exist in every single reality.
So in every reality there's a Wanda.
In every reality there's a Kang.
So when Kang
the Conqueror comes up with this plan
to erase all the dangerous timelines that
could theoretically save the multiverse,
it means that he'll be killing
a bunch of kangs who are on the council.
They don't want that. Like,
No, we're not going to let you kill us.
So the council gangs up and is able to
sabotage his time ship and his technology
and strand him in the quantum realm
outside of time and space.
That's basically
when the events of the movie pick up.
And if you're still confused about
where he who remains fits into all this,
like when did he win the Kang
Multiverse War?
That was the first version of events,
essentially when Kang
the Conqueror came up with his plan
to get rid of the dangerous timelines.
That's
when he started the Kang Multiverse War.
Like that erupted.
They ganged up on him,
and then exiled him.
But then he, who remains, eventually
went on to win the Kang Multiverse War
and basically did the same thing.
Like he got
rid of all of the other Kang variants
so that only his timeline remained
once isolated. On timeline.
All I have to do
is manage the flow of time and prevent
any further branches.
Hence the TVA.
He live for millions of years
and just got really bored of it.
And that's why he wanted Sylvie and Loki
to either take over for him
Willy Wonka style or kill him.
That's why we call he who remains
the Willy Wonka version of Kang,
because the plot of Loki season
one basically winds up
being the plot of the Willy Wonka movie.
Who can I Trust to run the factory when I
leave and take care of the envelope?
It's when he dies,
the multiverse is freed.
All the other cases rise up again.
The counsel of Kang Forms again.
And there you go.
Here's where we get to Avengers
Kang Dynasty and Secret Wars.
What?
Immortal is Scarlet, Centurion and Rama
Tut mean when they say they're certain
that he's dead.
They're talking about the exiled one,
Kang the Conqueror.
Well, Marvel seems like they're teasing.
Is it the council
no longer thinks that he's a threat,
so they just completely forget about him
and focus on The Avengers
and the other characters
from the multiverse
that are starting to mess
with the multiverse.
There's been a long time rumored
that Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty.
Since we know we're getting Secret Wars,
The Avengers are going to take a huge
L during that
and they'll separate the movies
with a big cliffhanger.
Kind of like the snap in Infinity War.
And then they'll pick up in Secret Wars
on Battle World.
So they'll be some God Emperor or Doom
or beyond or type of character to surface.
At the end of Kang Dynasty in Collapse
the rest of the multiverse in Create
battle World with characters
from all the different surviving
pieces of universes like Fox Marvel
characters, Wolverine, X-Men, Fox,
Fantastic Four, Tobey Maguire, Andrew
Garfield, Spider-Man, so on, so forth.
All fighting to stop whoever
that main villain winds up being in secret
wars, rumored to be another Kang variant.
And if this Kang said that he's obsessed
with destroying the Council
of Kang's like,
he wanted to do that before he started
going around erasing other timelines.
Early theory
is that something happens to him
while he's inside this multiverse drive.
Like when he gets sucked into there,
something happens to him.
He gains way more power
and then resurfaces
at the end of Kang dynasty
to kill the Council of Kangs
like the Avengers
aren't powerful enough to stop them.
But this other Kang who returns is
and he winds up
being some sort of amalgam
version of God Emperor Doom in the 1980s.
Secret Wars version of that beyond Earth.
He then collapses.
The rest of the multiverse, creates
battle world, and they spend that movie
with Multiverse Avengers trying to stop
him and rebuild, recreate the multiverse.
There were a lot of people
after the movie that were like,
No way Ant-Man would ever be able
to kill Kang the Conqueror.
What if they're correct
and he did not kill Kang The Conqueror?
He's still alive right now.
The rumor is that in Avengers
5 Kang Dynasty, Tom Holland
signed some mega deal to come back
and do more Spider-Man movies.
And as part of that, he's
going to be one of,
if not the main character in Avengers
5, Kang Dynasty.
I'm not sure I understand it all myself,
but here's what I know.
There's this intergalactic entity
named the Beyond Earth
and he wants to see who would win
in a battle of good against evil.
Will also meet a version
of the new Avengers team
in Captain America for Early.
Learn who's going to be on the team
in Avengers 5 will mostly be about that
group of characters from the MCU versus
the Council of Kangs.
The dynasty of Kangs in Secret
Wars is supposed to be more of a swansong
for Hugh Jackman's Wolverine,
the Fox X-Men, the legacy characters
like Patrick Stewart, Magneto, Fox,
Fantastic Four, Tobey Maguire, Andrew
Garfield, Spider-Man,
all those older versions of the characters
from the older movies,
their team of Multiverse Avengers defeats
whoever this new Kang variant
winds up being, and then they rebuild
the multiverse kind of like the ending
of the more modern version of Secret Wars,
where just like Infinity War in Avengers
Endgame, bunch of people wind up dying
and then they bring them all back
at the end of the last movie.
The other rumor is that
they're also going to use Marvel.
Phase
seven is a start of a big X-Men phase
in When they fix everything at the end of
Secret Wars, they're going to fix things
with just a few minor changes like,
Oh, by the way, budget
X-Men mutants popping up now
because of the way we fix things.
I'm expecting them to roll real hard on
X-Men in Marvel, Phase seven and beyond.
I also think there might be
some real world contractual issues
that's causing that to happen
to like the reason why they're waiting
so long to do hardcore X-Men stuff.
But since Avengers Kang
Dynasty isn't coming till spring 2025,
Loki Season
two in a little while is the next place
we're going to see the counsel of Kang's
other Kang variants.
That's what that second Post-Credits
scene is all about.
Teasing Loki season two with Loki
and Mobius going after the Victor
timely variant of Kang back in the 1800s
during season two.
They'll be continuing to do stuff
like that.
They'll go on regular missions
trying to stop Nexus events
with Big Marvel Easter Egg characters,
but also trying to figure out
what's going on with the Council of Kangs.
Remember, we'll see a bunch of these
different variants in upcoming movies
and Disney Plus series.
Let me know in the comments,
upcoming series
that you know about in Marvel Phase 5,
Which variants
do you want to see pop up in those?
Even though I'm not expecting to see Dr.
Doom in the new Fantastic Four movie,
it would be crazy
if they tease Doctor Doom,
but it winds up being the Kang
variant of Dr. Doom.
We're going to get a bunch of secret
invasion trailers really soon.
I'll do more videos for that
as soon as we do
The Mandalorian Season three episodes.
Also coming next, of course, I'll be doing
episode videos for that
to everyone, click here for my Full
Breakdown and Easter Eggs for Ant-Man
and the Wasp Quantumania and click here
for my full Post-Credits scenes video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.